Oh hi everyone you know I really do love
my Nintendo DSi or I used to love my
Nintendo DSi because now I would never
even think of using this thing ever
again what you say how could that
possibly be true
well it's because I've now have a
Nintendo DSi XL this is going to come
out here in America in early 2010 it's
out in Japan right now that's why we
have this and as you can see it is
basically gigantic the screens are
almost twice as big as the original DSi
screens and that's pretty much the only
thing that's different about the DSi XL
but let me tell you the DSi XL is
basically amazing the the screens are
bigger the the pixels are each just a
little bit bigger so it's the same
resolution now sometimes when you're
playing a game you are gonna be able to
see when you look at the big screens
you're gonna see okay well maybe the
pixels are a little bit too big if the
if the graphics have been designed for
the original DSi screens it might look a
little bit pixelated but not all the
time and actually it really really looks
fantastic I've been playing the new
Professor Layton game which you know I
love on my DSi XL and it really looks
gorgeous and to go back to the original
DSi screens which seemed fine at the
time now seem like I'm playing on these
on these tiny little postage stamps of
screens compared to the massive massive
beautiful screen area that we've got
here on the DSi XL and Japan it costs a
little bit more than the DSi it costs
about about roughly $200 that's probably
what it'll cost when it comes out here
but it does in addition to a normal
stylus pen it actually comes with this
also gigantic stylus pen for for extra
added comfort it's a little
uncomfortable because it's a bit heavy
to hold it like this and play like this
holding it with one hand the buttons and
everything are all still the same size
when you're playing normally to hold it
like a book like this for games like
Brain Age it's actually a little bit
more comfortable so yeah I'm a huge fan
of the DSi XL I didn't think I would be
I didn't know why I needed bigger
screens but after playing it for just a
little while I totally get it
gonna give this one a 9 out of 10
you